bonjour Christophe BECHU bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité politique
ce matin ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires on est ensemble pendant un
petit peu plus de 20 minutes on va
commencer en parlant du climat social et
c'est manifestations du 1er mai ont donc
été émaillé de violence Élisabeth borne
les a dénoncé hier dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée un nouveau palier a été
franchi a-t-elle dit est-ce que vous
redoutez une radicalisation du mouvement
et que de nouveaux paliers soit encore
franchi lors des prochaines journées
[Musique]
tous ceux qui
justifie qui explique que c'est parce
que le gouvernement n'écoute pas ou que
ce serait lié aux violences policières
ou aux consignes qui ont été des
commencez à mettre un mai dans une
phrase qui consiste à condamner des
violences c'est déjà s'écarter de ce qui
devrait être une colonne vertébrale
républicaine pour chacun précisément
évidemment d'abord Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui souffle sur les braises qui a tenu
des propos sur la police qui sont juste
inacceptables en donnant le sentiment
qu'elle que c'est elle qui est à
l'origine de ces de ces violences mais
ce que je regrette au delà de de sa
position à lui c'est la petite musique
d'ambiance qui qui tend à s'accoutumer à
s'habituer à ces violences et à leur
donner à la fois une sorte comment
dirais-je de gage on en a connu par le
passé il y en a déjà eu au cours de ces
dernières semaines c'est parce qu'il y a
pas eu de concession enfin si on ne
commence pas par une dénonciation
absolue de ce sujet où on va un jour on
expliquera que le manque de respect de
son voisin ou le fait de pas avoir été
entendu sur tel ou text 7 textes ça
justifie d'aller casser sa fenêtre ou de
crever ses pneus donc il entretient les
violences Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais bien
entendu par son silence par la manière
dont il dit les choses et même par la
petite musique qui laisserait entendre
que c'est faute d'obtenir des avancées
dans un cadre démocratique que les
choses se passent de cette manière c'est
juste pas possible votre ville Angers a
été touchée elle fait partie des villes
qui ont été assez fortement touchées par
les violences lundi avec des
dégradations des affrontements en
centre-ville comment vous réagissez face
à ces violences dans votre ville je suis
écoeuré comme l'écrasante majorité des
enjeuxvins et comme une large partie de
ceux qui ont manifesté en marge du 1er
mai quand vous avez des individus qui
prennent des des bars à
pour faire en sorte de fissurer les vide
de l'Hôtel de Ville quel est le sens de
ça quel est le prétexte pour lesquels on
fait des choses à quoi ça sert de casser
des abrébus alors que ça rend un service
à la population et comment dans la tête
on se retrouve à venir à une
manifestation quelle que soit le sujet
avec un mortier artifice ou un cocktail
Molotov en se disant que c'est un mode
d'expression qui entendable donc il y a
renforcé et à durcir à la fois les
sanctions contre qui sont contre ceux
qui sont pris et il y a au-delà de ça
être dans une posture globale dans
lesquelles on les sort totalement du jeu
d'abord des manifs mais ensuite
potentiellement de nos rues avec les
règles qui vont bien comment le jour
d'une fête du travail qui que ce soit
peut trouver normal que 450 hommes et
femmes qui faisaient leur travail de
policiers de force de l'ordre et qui
protège la manifestation se retrouve
blessé un moment ou un autre il y a des
interrogations sur le fait que le
gouvernement sait que des Black Blocs
vont venir anticipent la venue de ces
Black Blocs mais ne les empêche pas
d'agir comment l'état du droit durcir le
droit
moi vous savez la loi j'ai un lutter
contre ces Black Blocs j'ai un principe
qui est très simple est-ce que en l'état
actuel du droit on a les moyens de
l'empêcher
non
on peut quand bien même on a des
renseignements qui nous laisse penser
que des individus viendraient il n'y a
pas aujourd'hui d'Arsenal juridique il y
avait une disposition dans la loi
anti-casseurs qui a été cassée par le
Conseil constitutionnel remettre sur le
métier le texte en se demandant quelle
est la formule qui permettrait comme il
y a des interdictions de stable de
trouver un dispositif qui permette
d'empêcher la venue à la manifestation
ou à défaut que ce soit une circonstance
aggravante pour une condamnation après
la manifestation ça me semble être le
moins intéressant
au moment des manifestations il y a
certainement plusieurs chemins
juridiques la seule chose que je sais
c'est que notre responsabilité
aujourd'hui c'est de protéger ceux qui
nous protège et on peut pas continuer à
se retrouver dans une situation où on
laisse des policiers et des policiers
être en première ligne face à des
expressions de violence comme celles
qu'on a pu constater le gouvernement va
préparer une nouvelle loi anti-casseurs
Antibi la Glock juste après ça n'est pas
mon périmètre ministériel direct mais il
ne vous a pas échappé qui avait d'abord
des voix plus largement dans le pays qui
s'était exprimé y compris ici au Sénat
et que le ministre de l'Intérieur avait
été très clair sur le sujet et qu'il le
souhaitait le vous êtes mise de la
cohésion des territoires le maire de
Lyon Grégory doute c'est lui aussi dont
la ville a été touchée par les violences
demande à l'état un fond quand les
commerçants touchés par ces violences
vous êtes favorables
des fonds le gouvernement on a mis
beaucoup en place y compris le fond vert
je suis d'ailleurs très heureux
d'être sur votre plateau pour annoncer
que nous avons cette nuit officiellement
franchit le millième lauréat du fond
vert on va faire partir un communiqué de
presse dans les mines qui viennent il
s'agit de l'école des hirondaux et des
hirondelles dans une commune de 1700
habitants des Yvelines qui va bénéficier
de de fond pour rénovation ensuite
l'accompagnement de ceux qui sont
victimes parce que je vais quand même
répondre à votre question
l'accompagnement de ceux qui sont
victimes de ces de ces violences et les
processus d'indemnisation il
correspondent dans chaque ville à la
possibilité que qu'on a pour pour agir
au gouvernement aujourd'hui et pas dans
une logique qui consiste à les mettre en
place des fonds d'indemnisation
nationaux par rapport à des débordements
qui peuvent être locaux et qui sont
suivis localement par les préfectures et
par les mairies donc plutôt non à la
demande de Grégory Doucet tout à fait le
Conseil constitutionnel va se prononcer
tout à l'heure sur la validité du RIB du
référendum demandé par la gauche vous
redoutez une décision qui pourrait
relancer la contestation d'abord
redouter ne change rien la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel et ensuite je
pense que les raisons pour lesquelles le
premier référendum d'initiative
populaire a été écarté conduiront sans
doute au rejet du deuxième ce serait
présomptueux d'aller expliquer que
il y aurions quelque sorte un âge limite
de départ en retraite qu'on ne pourrait
pas dépasser quel que soit les
circonstances que nous rencontrerons une
génération doit pas se dire qu'elle va
fixer une sorte de borne ou de limite
indépassable si on a augmenté la durée
de cotisation et reculer l'âge de départ
à la retraite c'est parce que
l'espérance de vie augmente et et
beaucoup de pays autour de nous pour ne
pas dire tous l'ont déjà fait dans des
proportions plus importantes que ce soit
pas populaire c'est certain aucune
réforme des retraites ne l'a été que ce
soit nécessaire c'est tout aussi certain
il y a un texte qui suscite beaucoup
d'exploits des sports chez les opposants
et chez les syndicats c'est la
propositions de loi du groupe liotte et
c'est examiné 8 juin à l'assemblée qui
vise à l'abrogation de la réforme de
retraite est-ce que vous pensez qu'elle
sera votée avec vos anciens amis des
républicains apporteront suffisamment de
voix pour qu'elles le soir
le 8 juin c'est encore dans longtemps il
est beaucoup de beaucoup de choses vont
se passer d'ici là mais
c'est quand même pour moi une vraie
déception de penser que des gens qui ont
fait campagne pour défendre la
candidature de Madame Pécresse qui est
proclamait ou effort que avec elle ce
serait les 65 ans comme âge de départ de
la retraite on dans un premier temps
expliqué que 65 ans ce serait trop puis
que 64 pour une partie d'entre eux
c'était trop et que 63 ce serait à peine
acceptable qui aujourd'hui prennent des
positions qui sont exactement inverse
celles qu'ils ont défendu dans les
électeurs il y a un peu plus d'un an et
je considère que on ne gagne pas on
crédibilité en cohérence et même en
respect de la part des électeurs quand
on change de position selon qu'on soit
dans la majorité ou dans l'opposition en
constance et la cohérence on a besoin et
ça n'est pas ce ne sont pas les qualités
que une partie des députés LR pas tous
mais qu'une partie des députés LR ont
démontré pendant l'examen du dossier des
retraites un manque de crédibilité chez
les républicains pour vous bien sûr
quand vous changez d'avis en fonction de
l'endroit où vous siégé dans l'hémicycle
je pense que ça rassure pas les Français
sur la fiabilité sur la force des
convictions que vous pouvez avoir et un
manque d'autorité d'érection t-il
président du parti qui lui soutient la
réforme il a été élu jusqu'à vent je
veux pas Nil blâmer ni à qui que ce soit
j'ai préféré son attitude et là le fait
qu'il est mis lui son vote en cohérence
avec ce qu'il a dit plutôt que ceux qui
ont tenté de se faire un nom sur cette
réforme des retraites notamment rien
Pradier oui au détriment de l'intérêt
général et courir après une aventure
personnelle ça n'a évidemment rien dit
légitime en démocratie mais le faire
dans un contexte comme celui que nous
connaissons et avec un système de
répartition qui est en déséquilibre
puisque nous avons moins de deux actifs
aujourd'hui par retraités ça n'est ni
digne très glorieux on va le président
de la République les ministres qui sont
chahutés lorsqu'ils se déplace sur le
terrain avec notamment des concerts de
casseroles est-ce que vous-même vous
avez dû renoncer à des déplacements les
déportés les différents modifier le
parcours
renoncer non ce n'est ni ne monte
tempérament ni la manière dont je vois
les choses en revanche j'ai eu droit à
des comités d'accueil à Vesoul la
semaine dernière où je me suis rendu
pour aller à la rencontre de
l'Association des Maires la veille dans
les Pyrénées-Orientales où je suis venu
parler sécheresses avec les acteurs de
ce département qui sont particulièrement
touchés
y compris dans une forêt au Mans pour
venir repérer des dispositifs de
prévention des de prévention des
incendies bref mais
très bien que que certains continuent de
manifester qu'il le fassent avec des
ustensiles de cuisine
[Musique]
ce que je veux dire c'est que il y a eu
à chaque réforme des retraites les
contestations des manifestations des
votes des expressions populaires et à
aucune
occasion d'alternance ce qui avait
combattu ses réformes ne sont ensuite
revenus dessus tout simplement parce que
la démographie ne ment pas et que la
situation dans laquelle on se trouve
aujourd'hui elle nous emmène dans une
impasse de modifie pas les règles parce
qu'on vit plus longtemps c'est ce que
encore une fois tous les pays européens
ont fait avant nous il y a rien
d'original dans ce que fait la France
elle le fait même avec un peu de retard
sur ses voisins et pour vous la gauche
le rassemblement national qui disent
qu'il reviendront sur cette réforme
s'ils arrivent au pouvoir ne le font pas
quand encore une fois je le redis tout
ce qui se sont opposés à des textes par
le passé ne sont jamais revenus dessus
quand ils se sont retrouvés en
responsabilité on va parler de
transition écologique et Elisabeth borne
a présenté la feuille des 100 jours la
semaine dernière avec une partie sur
l'écologie notamment une loi sur
l'industrie verte est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire plus sur ce que contient
cette loi vous avez plus de détails bien
sûr quatre grands chapitres
un premier qui consiste à faciliter les
implantations industrielles à partir
d'une idée simple c'est que ce qu'on
produit en Europe a un meilleur bilan
carbone que ce qu'on produit au bout du
monde il n'y a pas besoin de l'amener
jusqu'ici et puis nos
usines ne sont pas alimentées par des
centrales à charbon mais par du
nucléaire qui est une énergie autrement
plus propre donc comment est-ce qu'on
facilite avec du foncier clairement avec
des procédures qui aille plus vite non
pas qu'il soit moins exigeant d'un point
de vue environnemental mais qu'on puisse
conduire en parallèle un certain nombre
de processus le deuxième volet c'est la
question du financement on a aujourd'hui
une offensive américaine avec
l'inflation de réduction actes qui
permet d'aller subventionner massivement
une partie de ces technologies verte
pour aller vers l'électrification vers
les énergies renouvelables il faut qu'il
y ait une réponse qui soit européenne
sur ces sujets comment est-ce qu’on est
capable d'aller mettre en place des
financements en mobilisant l'épargne
privée en faisant en sorte de permettre
des crédits ou des remises d'impôts
troisième volet c'est celui qui consiste
à favoriser
ça n'est pas un gros mot par la commande
publique
l'industrie française ou européenne et
on pense en particulier aux voitures
électriques en disant ça comment est-ce
qu'on fait en sorte d'utiliser les
leviers qui sont les nôtres plutôt que
d'aller subventionner de manière
indirecte l'industrie chinoise pour
aider donc changer les règles rien du
trialisation bien sûr et changer les
règles notamment européennes il y a trop
de naïveté de la part de l'Union
européenne évidemment trop naïvetés
pendant longtemps on a considéré que le
fait de d'être ouvert au monde et de
faire en sorte de jouer
librement j'allais dire le commerce
était un système viable bilan on se
retrouve aujourd'hui à une échelle
européenne avec une naïveté qui consiste
à verser des subventions à des pays qui
eux en retour ne nous envers pas
ça pendant des années accéléré une forme
de désindustrialisation sortir de cette
naïveté c'est assumer le fait qu'il y a
une préférence européenne ou française
dans la commande publique et dans les
soutiens qui peuvent être apportés et
c'est une nécessité parce qu'on est dans
un temps où ce sujet de transition
écologique il est partout et il y a une
forme de Yalta industriel qui est en
train de s'implanter dans les grandes
filières par exemple des voitures
électriques des énergies renouvelables
de toutes les technologies bas carbone
et il est crucial que dans cette phase
on puisse le faire c'est ce qui se
passera on facilitant des implantations
en finance en mieux la transition
écologique en faisant en sorte de
favoriser les commandes et enfin en
permettant dans le cadre de ce PJL
d'accélérer la formation de celles et
ceux dont on a besoin pour travailler
dans le champ du nucléaire où il y a des
milliers d'emplois qui vont être rendus
nécessaires parce qu'il est en train de
se passer mais pas seulement beaucoup
d'emplois d'ingénieurs en particulier
avec un enjeu de féminisation aussi sur
tout ça qui est extrêmement fort parmi
les autres annonces des abattement dans
un com un terme ministériel sur le vélo
ce sera quand et ça pourrait déboucher
sur quoi ce sera vendredi en tout début
d'après-midi j'aurais l'occasion avec
Clément bonne d'accueillir l'ensemble
des partenaires du vélo il faut se
souvenir que le premier plan vélo qui
est jamais été présenté à l'échelle de
notre pays il date de 2018 et d'isabeth
était la ministre des Transports qui l'a
présenté en 2018 on avait annoncé je
m'en souviens parce que les annonces
avaient été faites à Angers par Édouard
Philippe 50 millions d'euros par an
pendant 7 ans pour le vélo et non
seulement cet argent a été dépensé mais
il a été beaucoup plus vite que ce qui
était prévu tentez si bien que dans le
cadre du plan de relance il y a des
crédits supplémentaires qui ont été
annoncés au début de cette année la
première ministre a indiqué que pour
l'année 2023 c'était 250 millions
d'euros pour la seule année qu'elle
avait mis qu'elle avait être mis en
place en particulier pour accompagner la
réalisation d'infrastructures des
soutiens diverses etc l'enjeu là c'est
de regarder au-delà de l'année 2023 et
c'est ce que nous allons faire dans ce
comité interministériel vélo vendredi
donc de nouveaux moyens
quelle politique cyclable pour les
années qui arrivent et jusqu'à la fin du
quinquennat et sans rien vous dévoiler
un peu comme nous avons une ambition
nous avons évidemment une ambition qui
continue à
se tourner vers le vélo pour plein de
raisons d'abord c'est évidemment un mode
de transport totalement des carboné qui
ensuite est bon pour la santé et on a
des enjeux industriels il y a un député
qui a fait un rapport le député Gouffier
chat sur l'intérêt qu'il y aurait à
imiter le Portugal en particulier qui
fait en sorte de produire des vélos
européens de façon plus plus importante
je pense qu'il y a là aussi à la
frontière entre le PG à l'industrie vert
dont on parlait les enjeux de transition
écologique des enjeux autour du
développement de d'usines qui puisse
nous permettre d'améliorer cette filière
vélo le ministre délégué à l'Industrie
qui est un grand cycliste selon Lescure
et attentif comme Clément bonne comme
moi-même on est convaincu que ça fait
partie des choses à faire avec la
Fédération des usagers de la bicyclette
en particulier il y a quelques jours
dans le journal Le Parisien Emmanuel
Macron a lancé un grand projet
de restauration écologique des écoles là
aussi quand sera-t-il lancé et comment
allez-vous accompagner les élus et les
communes puisqu'il a parlé de les
accompagner il sera lancé le 9 mai c'est
précis c'est dans une semaine un peu
moins même maintenant avec
une présentation de ce que sont les
trois leviers les trois outils qui vont
être mis en place dans le cadre de cette
rénovation le 1er j'en ai indirectement
parlé en
vantant les mérites de ce fond vert qui
est un immense succès puisqu'on a
dépassé les 10000 dossiers déposés
2 milliards d'euros d'aide pour tout ce
qui est bon pour le climat ou la
biodiversité ça correspond à un
doublement des enveloppes de soutien aux
collectivités c'était 2 milliards
d'euros en année normal on est passé à 4
milliards en 2023 et se font
frapperennisé donc on va d'abord
repréciser ce qui est une partie des
règles deuxième levier le tiers
financement
j'ai évoqué le fait qu'il y avait une
forme de chantier du siècle qui était
possible on a 400 millions de mètres
carrés de bâtiment public l'enjeu c'est
qu'on a modifié le code de la commande
publique ça s'est passé il y a quelques
jours au mois d'avril de manière
définitive avec un texte voté à
l'unanimité à l'Assemblée au Sénat et
qui permet de lisser les investissements
n'étant pas obligé de commencer par
payer les travaux mais de le faire au
fur et à mesure des années grâce aux
économies d'énergie qu'on réalise et
enfin la banque des territoires qui est
non commerciale de la banque
pardon la banque des territoires qui est
donc le nom commercial de la Caisse des
dépôts et consignations présentera un
dispositif que je lui ai demandé de
concevoir et de mettre en place
d'appuyer à l'ingénierie pour que les
collectivités puissent à la fois avoir
les leviers de financement mais les
conseils pour lancer cette rénovation et
l'ambition c'est 10000 écoles d'ici la
fin du quinquennat dont nous pourrons
lancer la rénovation parmi les
inquiétudes il y a évidemment la
question de la sécheresse début mars
vous appeliez les préfets assigner sans
trembler des arrêtés sécheresses quelle
est la situation aujourd'hui et et
notamment peut-être sur le front des
pénuries d'eau puisqu'il y a des
communes qui connaissent des pénuries
d'eau combien de communes sont en
tension actuellement
on a terminé l'été 2022 avec des nappes
au plus bas nous n'avons pas eu un
automne qui a permis de les recharger et
on a même eu une sécheresse hivernale
avec 32 jours sans plus
on a eu un mois de mars qui globalement
a été bénéfique pour le nord et l'ouest
de la France mais sans plus sur le
pourtour méditerranéen et le couloir
redania à la minute où on se parle
on a donc 75% du pays dans lequel les
nappes phréatiques sont en dessous
des normales de saison mais on a des
inquiétudes très concentrés sur le
pourtour méditerranéen la Corse et le
couloir rhodanien où on a à la fois les
niveaux les plus bas les recharges les
plus basses et les perspectives qui sont
pas les plus réjouissantes et dans ces
territoires on a déjà atteint les
niveaux crises sur une partie du Var des
Bouches-du-Rhône et sur le département
des Pyrénées Orientales où il n'a pas
plus depuis un an pas de pluie
significative
on est dans cet anticipation j'ai eu
l'occasion il y a quelques jours
seulement de tenir un nouveau comité
d'anticipation sécheresse
après l'été qu'on a vécu on a lancé 500
travaux d'interconnexion dans divers
endroits de France parce que vous l'avez
dit on a eu près de 1000 communes qu'on
connu des difficultés d'eau potable près
de 400 qui ont été alimentés par citerne
200 par des bouteilles en plastique et à
la minute on se parle on a à nouveau des
communes qui sont dans cette situation
certaines depuis plusieurs semaines on
est en train de consolider ce chiffre on
aura un dispositif qui nous permettra de
le connaître en temps réel quand l'été
va commencer mais on est un peu en
avance de phase à ce stade c'est encore
très faible c'est quatre par exemple
pour le département des des
Pyrénées-Orientales ce chiffre était le
plus élevé pendant l'été dernier mais on
est évidemment à la fois inquiet
concentré pour faire en sorte d'avoir
les remontées d'un fouet de pouvoir
accompagner les territoires ça permet de
bien mesurer en creux qu'on doit faire
davantage de travaux pour interconnecter
les collectivités entre elles et il faut
qu'on arrive à trouver un chemin
entre la mutualisation des services
d'eau parce que continuer à gérer en
commun isoler ça n'est pas possible il
faut dire que
les trois quarts des communes qui ont
plus 50% de taux de fuite ce sont des
communes qui gèrent toutes seules leur
eau potable et qui ne font pas dans un
cadre intercommune il faut rappeler que
l'écrasante majorité des communes qu'on
a des problèmes d'eau potable c'est pas
ce qu'elle gère seul ou avec des toutes
petites unités leur système d'eau donc
il faut qu'on arrive à trouver à pousser
à l'intercommunalité ou à défaut puisque
le président de la République a dit que
il pourrait y avoir des formes plus
souples qui sont à travailler en
particulier avec le Sénat qu'on est des
regroupements de communes pour arrêter
d'avoir des communes isolées c'est une
condition absolue pour être capable de
faire face à ces sécheresses qui
malheureusement s'annoncent
pas sur la base du volontariat nous
allons clairement il y a aujourd'hui une
obligation d'intercommunalité la
réflexion c'est de légèrement
l'assouplir pour rendre possible
d'autres formes d'associations en
revanche
l'interdiction de la gestion en commun
isolée de l'eau potable elle est
extrêmement claire elle a été déjà dans
les textes et elle le restera dans
quelques instants on va avoir un débat
sur l'autoroute a69 dont les travaux ont
commencé quel moment bonne l'a rappelé
hier qui doit relier Castres à Toulouse
est-ce que vous défendez ce projet et
Clément Bonnières a dit qu'il voulait
discuter avec le concessionnaire pour
des améliorations sur les aspects
environnementaux vous les souhaitez
lesquels
le ministre des Transports a dit que
l'autoroute se ferait que les travaux
avaient commencé qu'on pouvait pas
comparer des projets pour lesquels ils
pouvaient y avoir une nouvelle analyse à
ce stade y compris parce que certains
peuvent être très vieux et que il est
toujours souhaitable y compris dans un
temps d'accélération de la transition
écologique de se demander si le bilans
quoi avantage sont à la hauteur en ce
qui concerne tout doucement on a la fois
une déclaration d'utilité publique des
décisions de justice une agglomération
d'un peu plus de 100.000 habitants qui
est la seule à ne pas être accordée par
une deux fois de voix à sa capitale
régionale et donc il peut y avoir des
améliorations mais elles seront à la
marge par rapport aux besoins de
réaliser le projet d'autant que pour
avoir regardé le dossier l'idée qui
consisterait à doubler la nationale
plutôt que l'autoroute elle entraînerait
presque le double en termes de coupure
d'arbre qui serait rendu nécessaire et
c'est un des points qui provoque des
réactions de la part de d'associations
ou de collectif donc il faut être très
clair les années qui viennent ne sont
pas des années dans lesquelles on va
accentuer le
les investissements routiers au
contraire la priorité c'est le
ferroviaire c'est d'insister sur la
régénération c'est les modes de mobilité
de vous c'est l'électrification du pays
mais pour autant ça veut pas dire que il
faut mettre tout le pays sous cloche et
qu'il n'y a pas des endroits où on a des
besoins de projets qui permettent
d'aller faire du désenclavement et de la
France n'est pas un pays isolée les
écologistes sont responsabilités en
Allemagne le gouvernement vient de
rendre public les 100 ou 140 dossiers
sur lequel il apporte en Allemagne un
soutien des projets routiers on est dans
la même optique priorité au ferroviaire
mais nécessité d'aller accompagner des
voix qui sont parfois nécessaires en
termes de disant clavement merci
Christophe Bachut merci beaucoup d'avoir
été et on va justement débattre de ces
projets merci bonne journée à vous